We came here to Nepal to actually oversee the measurement of the height of Khagendra...
...which was taken by a doctor at the hospital.
We have very strict and precise rules for how the measurement should be taken for the shortest man.
He has to be measured three times a day:...
...in the morning, at noon, and in the evening.
And then, we take the average measurement for official result of the record.
The shortest man record is one that grabs people's attention from all over the world.
And 2010 has seen a lot occur in this record category.
Sadly, He Pingping died early this year.
And then, the world was left wondering who the next shortest person would be.
We discovered a man, Edward Niño Hernandez in Colombia, in Bogota early this year...
...and he held the record for a few months,...
...but now, the record officially belongs to Khagendra here in Nepal.
We've known Khagendra for a while now.
It's actually, he's been on our database as the shortest teenager for a few months already...
...and we were waiting for him to turn 18,...
...and become an adult before we could measure him...
...for the record for the shortest man.
And we've done this today, and it's fantastic that we could do it on his birthday.